Holho is a pyramid screen you put on your
smartphone or tablet to project holographic
images.
And scientists in Taipei have developed a
smart tooth sensor that monitors your oral
hygiene including flossing habits and smoking
and reports them to your dentist.
Vsauce! Kevin here. This is Mind Blow.
This is a living creature that looks like
a rock. It's completely immobile and it eats
by sucking in water and filtering out microorganisms.
It reproduces by throwing clouds of sperm
and eggs into the water to make more living
rock babies. So yeah.
SmileDrive is gameifying driving. Volkswagen
and Google have combined to create a social
app that awards stickers for unlocking achievements
such as a 100 mile trip or passing someone
driving the same model car as you. It works
with any car and even has a feature called
SmileCast that creates a travelogue of pictures
and posts during your trip and collects them
on a single URL.
The Online Electric Vehicle or OLEV seeks
to make public transportation cleaner for
the environment by using buses powered by
a power line installed under the road. The
battery is only used in emergency situations
with the high-efficiency onboard pickup device
using what they call segmentation control
technology that only powers those segments
of the line the vehicle at that time needs
to move. They're still working it make it
more efficient so they can make it commercially
available.
Høvding is an airbag for bicyclists. Designed
as a master thesis at the University of Lund
in Sweden - the idea was to create a protective
device for adults who hate wearing helmets.
It's worn as a collar around your neck that
can be stylishly hidden with a scarf but inflates
to protect the head in the event of an accident.
Check out the website for more.
Created at the Laboratory of Intelligent Systems,
the deployable air land exploration robot
or DALER is a robot designed to fly and walk
on its wings. By using the wings on rough
terrain instead of legs the amount of mass
is minimized and the lighter weight allows
for greater flight performance. It has the
ability to move on different surfaces, climb
high obstacles, and navigate rough terrains.
On Land Or On Sea. Amphibious RV. Sorry.
A remote medical care robot is being developed
at Waseda University that will allow emergency
personnel to check for internal injuries before
the patient gets to the hospital. The device
can be attached to the patient while on the
way to the hospital and a doctor can control
it from a remote location. They're starting
with remote pregnancy check up and are hoping
to have it used in practical applications
within three years.
The Crabster CR200 is a six-legged underwater
robot developed by the Korean Institute of
Ocean Science and Technology. It was designed
to reach places that current propelled designs
can't because of strong currents, giving it
the ability to easily walk along the ocean
floor. It takes 4 people to operate and uses
the front legs that are equipped with manipulators
to grasp things similar to a real crab and
it can stay on the sea floor for days at a
time.
Enevo has come up with a way to make collecting
trash more efficient with a sensor that alerts
trash collectors when a dumpster is full - so
they're not wasting time and energy picking
up half dumpsters. It's called One-collect
and it uses real time fill level information
and advanced algorithms to calculate the best
route so companies are only collecting the
full containers each day. And it's said to
save 20-40% in costs.
TVILight are developing intelligent street
lighting for up to 80% energy savings, 50%
maintenance cost reduction, lower carbon footprint
and a reduction in light pollution. Using
plug and play wireless sensors the lights
dim to pre-defined levels during off-peak
hours unless a human is detected and individual
lights can be remotely monitored and controlled.
They also adjust due to weather conditions
and return to normal operating mode in the
event of a system failure.
Animal Jewelry project to show the fashion
industry that fur is alive.
German researchers successfully froze light
for a minute. Basically, they shot a laser
through a crystal which sent its atoms into
two states and then switched off the first
laser with a second beam and trapped the second
laser beam inside - stopping light. Got that?
And this is a huge step in building light-based
quantum memory.
Scientists at Wake Forest University's Military
Research Center are developing a method to
print skin cells onto burn wounds. By taking
the healthy cells of a patient grown in an
incubator they're able to put them into an
empty cartridge and print them directly onto
the skin. A camera and laser is used to scan
the burn and create a 3D map of the wound
and the computer then tells the printer how
many and what type of skin cells are needed
to fill each area of the wound, where they
then become new skin cells.
University of Michigan engineers have created
stretchable conductors using polyurethane
studded with gold nano particles. The material
conducts electricity even while stretched
and could be used in the future in flexible
electronics and gentler medical devices.
Finally, Crystals is an audio visual collaboration
using stop motion photography that captured
crystals growing under a microscope. And it
was made by artist Bruno Levy and DJ Kate
Simko
I'm gonna leave you with a robot displaying
animal like step reflexes.
And as always — for watching.
[AquaTop Display
Projection System Using White Water As Surface]
[When the magic circle is thrown,
the small speaker array provides haptic feedback
as recoil for the attack
as well as when an enemy is destroyed.]
[Flicking the magic circle away (moving and submerging the finger) will 'throw' the magic circle.]
[If the magic circle hits the enemy jellyfish,
the jellyfish will explode.]
Make sure that you follow me on Twitter at
VsauceTwo. Where I share things that aren't
in videos like this frog holding a leaf umbrella.
And other mind blowing stuff. So go do it
now.
Okay?
Go do it now.